-My first guest is a three-time
Grammy-winning artist.
His concert film
"Magnificent Coloring World"
will be coming exclusively
to AMC Theatres this summer.
Here he is, Chance the Rapper!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yeah, that's what
I'm talking about!
That's my friend. Come on, bud!
Looking great.
-Hey, man.
-Looking sharp, bud, as always.
Thanks so much
for coming on the show.
-Red carpet ready.
Oh, thanks, man.
-Yeah, please.
How are you doing?
How is the fam?
How are the kids?
-Everybody is good.
We got --
My wife's in the other room.
She's getting hair and makeup
and all types of stuff
ready for tonight's premiere.
And the kids are
with their grandparents.
So it's going to be
a wild night.
-Yeah. Good. I like wild nights.
Look at how cute --
How old are they right now?
-That's Kensli and Marli.
They are five and two.
[ Laughter ]
-And they're into
the whole princess thing, huh?
-Yeah.
I don't remember -- I think that
was, like, one of her friends
had, like,
an elaborate birthday party
where they were all princesses.
So we went all out and got both
of them princess outfits.
-Yeah. My girls dress like this
to go to school.
[ Laughter ]
That's what they --
They just love it so much.
I go, "Yeah, just go for it.
I don't care."
What are you gonna do?
-Yeah.
-Last time you were on,
we talked about how much you --
your love of movies.
Are you showing the kids movies
like your favorite
when you were a kid?
-Oh, yeah. All the classics.
My oldest daughter
is really into "Spy Kids,"
which I don't know
if you remember "Spy Kids,"
but it was amazing.
-Yeah, I love "Spy Kids."
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yeah.
-It's great.
-Give it up for "Spy Kids."
It's amazing. And she
actually got hooked on it
because she found out about
Sharkboy and Lavagirl
from "We Can Be Heroes,"
which is a new movie on Netflix
that all the kids love.
But they don't know
it's connected to my childhood.
I grew up on
Sharkboy and Lavagirl.
-Wow!
-Pretty cool connection there.
Love of the films.
-You are actually
doing a reboot,
I want to say, of "Home Alone."
Is that tr--
Did I read that right?
-[ Chuckles ]
It's a secret.
I'm working on -- I got this
pitch for a "Home Alone" reboot.
As a lot of people know --
I'm sure everybody here is
a huge fan of "Home Alone."
-Of course.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-John Hughes.
-Macaulay Culkin.
-Chicago guy.
Yeah, Macaulay Culkin.
Chicago film.
And since I was younger,
I always watched it.
And I was like, what if there
was a hood "Home Alone"?
Or "Hood Alone," if you will?
[ Laughter ]
And just based -- just
a little more realistic story
about what happens
when people try
and kick in doors
at the wrong house.
[ Laughter ]
And, you know, hilarity ensues.
I can't give you
too many details,
but yeah,
thanks for saying that.
Yes, hood "Home Alone."
-I like that. I like that.
Is one -- Is one kid Kevin?
-There's two kids.
But, uh, it's up for grabs.
You want to get in
on this project?
-Yeah, yeah, yeah, I'm in.
Ground floor.
I want to get in on
this "Hood Alone."
What are we calling it?
-[ Laughing ] "Hood Alone."
"Hood Alone."
Write it down, please.
-I want to deal with
your production company,
which by the way, I love
the name -- House of Kicks.
-House of Kicks. Yeah.
-Was that sneakers? What is it?
-It's not. It's not sneakers.
Why does everybody think it has
to do with shoes?
So, it's House of Kicks.
It's my film house.
It's where we make our movies
out of.
And the name comes from
House of Kicks,
which was this black-owned
theme park
that all the kids in Chicago
used to go to.
Like, all the day camps and
schools would take their kids
on field trips
to the House of Kicks.
It was this big indoor place
of wonder on the South Side
where there was not a lot of --
nothing that looked like that.
And when I first started
building, you know,
the film house
and getting into film stuff,
I wanted it to feel like
an amusement park.
So yep, House of Kicks --
no shoes involved.
-No, yeah. I love that.
Yeah, you just want to have fun.
That's all.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yeah.
Thank you. Thank you, guys.
-You made this concert film,
which I'm a fan of.
"The Magnificent
Coloring World."
-Yeah.
-What made you do it?
You shot this
a couple years ago, right?
-Yeah. I think I told you
about it when I first started.
So, basically
it's four years old.
It was a film that I shot right
after I won the Grammys in 2017.
I came back to Chicago right
after finishing up this tour,
getting ready to go on
another one.
And I just had this idea
that I wanted to do a concert
but specifically for film
and it'd be shot
like it was a movie
and eventually put it out
in theaters.
And it came together
in like three weeks,
a bunch of years back,
and it was amazing.
It was a beautiful experience,
but I didn't really know a lot
about film at all
or how to edit or anything.
And so about three weeks ago,
I sent out for the film
and brought it
to the studio house
and worked tirelessly on it
with about 20 people,
and, you know, shot some
new stuff, and also ended up
working out a partnership
with AMC Theatres
to get it distributed.
And now I'm the first ever
independent distributor --
artist and distributor of a film
in AMC history.
So things come together quickly
if you try hard.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Right?
-Get the right people.
-By the way, I wanted to mention
how great you were
on "Saturday Night Live."
I thought you were fantastic
when you hosted.
-Thank you, man.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Talented dude.
-I appreciate it.
-Talented guy.
I want to show everyone a clip.
Here's a peek at
"Magnificent Coloring World."
Take a look at this.
♪ -It's so natural ♪
♪ Tastes like Juicy Fruit ♪
♪ Works like a ♪
♪ We don't, we don't,
we don't, we don't, we don't ♪
♪ Don't you color out ♪
♪ Don't you bleed on out ♪
♪ Stay in the line, stay in ♪
♪ Dandelion ♪
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-That's gonna be fun to see that
in the theater.
Play it loud.
-Something new.
-That's gonna be cool.
Chance the Rapper, everybody.